[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers in
allen einen guten Samstagabend der Start
zahlt uns allen den Energiepreis genauer
den Teil davon der eine bestimmte Grenze
übersteigt er muss dafür aber
interessanterweise weniger Geld ausgeben
als gedacht weil die Energiepreise
gerade sowieso auf breiter Front
gesunken sind jetzt will der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister der Industrie
unter die Arme greifen die viel Energie
verbraucht sie soll einen deutlich
vergünstigten Strompreis bekommen und
das geht nur durch massive staatliche
Subventionen wie das funktionieren soll
was es für Folgen hätte und was der
Finanzminister dazu sagt die Anna
zimmermann
Stahl kochen und Energiesparen das passt
kaum zusammen für viele Branchen ist der
Strompreis ein entscheidender
Kostenfaktor und der ist in Deutschland
hoch Gewerkschaften und Industrie
schlagen Alarm warnen vor dem Verlust
hunderttausender Jobs der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister will nun
übergangsweise Industriestrom
subventionieren
der Zugang zu erneuerbaren Energien ist
der industriestrompreis der Zukunft die
müssen aber in den großen Mengen
ausgebaut werden bis dahin bin ich der
Meinung dass man für die sich im
internationalen Wettbewerb befindliche
Industrie die sonst abwandern wird und
die hochenergieintensiv ist eine weitere
Hilfeleistung geben muss Zustimmung
kommt in dieser Sache auch von der CDU
die Bundesregierung hat eine Zusage
gegeben einen industriestrompreis in
Deutschland zu etablieren die
Bundesregierung muss dieses Versprechen
einlösen
2021 war es und der Kanzler erst
Kandidat da versprach Olaf Scholz der
Industrie die Kilowattstunde sondern nur
noch vier Cent kosten das ist seit dem
Ukraine Krieg in weite Ferne gerückt nun
soll der Preis immerhin auf unter 10
Cent reduziert werden mindestens sechs
Milliarden Euro wird das Kosten grün und
SPD finden das Geld soll er aus dem im
vergangenen Jahr geschaffenen Wirtschaft
stabilisierungsvorkommen
diesen Topf werden wir nach allen
Voraussicht nach nicht ausschöpfen so
dass hier eine logische
Weiterentwicklung auch mit diesen
Mitteln möglich ist und ich gehe davon
aus dass der Finanzminister dem auch
zustimmen wird der und seine FDP
allerdings gehen davon nicht aus wenn
das Geld nicht abgerufen wird ist das
gut weil es ist ein schafhaushalt nicht
weiter belastet über eine Schulden für
die ja jetzt sehr sehr teure Zinsen
fällig werden und deswegen ist das
sicherlich kein valider Vorschlag
während sich in der Ampel der nächste
Konflikt anbahnt äußert das Deutsche
Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung ganz
fundamentale Kritik
die die Industrialisierung ist eine
reale Gefahr für Deutschland aber nicht
wegen zu hohe Energiekosten sondern weil
die deutschen Unternehmen die
ökologische und digitale Transformation
weiter verschlafen das ist die Gefahr
Subvention von Produktion über
Energiekosten ist der falsche Weg es ist
Irrweg der langfristig die die
Industrialisierung eher beschleunigen
wird und nicht verändern wird Gegenwind
ist auch aus Brüssel zu erwarten wie
schon bei der Gas und strompreisbremse
wird kritisiert das reiche Deutschland
Verzerrer mit seinen Subventionen den
Wettbewerb innerhalb der EU
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck ist aktuell noch bei einem
anderen Thema in den Schlagzeilen da
geht es um Personalpolitik im
Ministerium und den Vorwurf der
Vetternwirtschaft Details dazu
ausführlich morgen in Berlin direkt nach
der 19 Uhr heute Sendung
während wir in der Ukraine aktuell einen
Krieg Erleben der zur großen Teilen
geführt wird wie die Weltkriege die wir
längst überwunden hofften mit der
tödlichen macht nämlich von Artillerie
und Panzern bereitet sich der kleine
Inselstaat Taiwan auf Angriffe vor bei
denen kein Blut fließt die aber auch
verheerende Folgen haben können speziell
für eine hoch digitalisierte
Gesellschaft wie die in Taiwan der
mächtige Nachbar China droht immer
massiver mit militärmanövern Taiwan baut
sich derweil eine cyber-festung Miriam
Steimer war dort
diese Supermärkte gibt es in Taiwans
Hauptstadt Taipei an jeder Straßenecke
Einkaufen Pakete abholen oder
Stromrechnung zahlen hier geht alles und
genau hier kam im vergangenen Herbst die
digitale Bedrohung plötzlich im Alltag
der Leute an auf dem Bildschirm über der
Kasse wo normalerweise Werbung läuft
stand plötzlich
kriegstreiberin pelosy raus aus Taiwan
ein Hackerangriff aus China
Nancy Pelosi damals Sprecherin des
US-Repräsentantenhauses besuchte Taiwan
für China dass die demokratische Insel
als Teil seines Staatsgebiets betrachtet
eine Provokation
untersucht solche Cyberangriffe täglich
die Leute merken jetzt vor allem nach
dem Palace sie Besuch wie verwundbar
unser System ist und was die chinesische
Seite anrichten kann
sie prüft woher solche Angriffe kommen
die Antwort immer häufiger aus China von
staatlicher Seite Firmen Privatpersonen
einen Grund Chinas aggressive
Außenpolitik
diese Atmosphäre fördert oder motiviert
anscheinend einige Sicherheitsfirmen
oder Hacker etwas zu machen und zu
zeigen dass sie ihr Land lieben dass sie
etwas für China machen wollen
in ihrem Büro befürchten Sie nicht dass
es zu einem Krieg mit China kommen
könnte sie sind mittendrin
längst statt jeden Tag gibt es Angriffe
der cyber-armee du spürst es nur nicht
aber die selber Army macht das jeden Tag
Taiwan wappnet sich gegen diese Angriffe
die Regierung fördert zum Beispiel die
drohnenbranche dieser Helikopter soll
empfangen bringen wenn ein Angriff
Telefon und internet-
das Ziel dieses Zentrums mit großem
Testfeld die besten Firmen des Landes
mit viel Geld zu Kooperationen
motivieren und Nummer eins in Asien
werden
Fortschritt der gesamten
drohnenindustrie beschleunigt und den
politischen Prozess vorangetrieben
diese Helikopter können flexibel bringen
was gebraucht wird Kameras Internet oder
Waffen falls es nicht beim Krieg der
Daten bleibt
so jetzt zurück nach Deutschland und zu
den Nachrichten im Überblick und damit
zu dir Hanna
Kinderärztinnen und Ärzte aus
Deutschland und anderen Ländern Europas
schlagen Alarm sie warnen in einem
offenen Brief vor einem verschärften
Mangel von kindermedikamenten und
fordern die Politik zum schnellen
Handeln auf die Engpässe würden die
Gesundheit der Kinder und Jugendlichen
nachhaltig gefährden heißt es in dem
Brief so vielen unter anderem
antibiotika-säfte aber auch Fieber und
Schmerzmedikamente
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
bezeichnete die Sorge als berechtigt und
verwies auf einen Gesetzentwurf des
Bundeskabinetts der die Engpässe
beseitigen soll
auf der von Russland annektierten
Halbinsel Krim ist ein Treibstofflager
explodiert laut dem dortigen Gouverneur
infolge eines ukrainischen
drohnenangriffs dieser wird aus Kiew
nicht bestätigt insgesamt sollen in der
Hafenstadt Sewastopol laut ukrainischen
Angaben zehn Tanks mit 40.000 Tonnen Öl
in Brand geraten sein mittlerweile sei
das Feuer gelöscht worden niemand wurde
verletzt
der Kompromiss der EU-Staaten zu
Getreide Importen aus der Ukraine ist
von der Regierung in Kiew begrüßt worden
Polen Bulgarien die Slowakei und Ungarn
wollen laut EU-Kommission ihre
Beschränkungen aufheben so dass der
Transit der Güter in andere Länder
wieder ermöglicht wird gleichzeitig
können Sie den inlandsverkauf einzelner
Produkte untersagen die vier Länder
hatten agrarimporte aus der Ukraine
beschränkt und damit auf Proteste von
heimischen Landwirten reagiert diese
sahen sich angesichts des preiswerten
Getreides aus der Ukraine bedroht
bei seinem Besuch in Ungarn hat Papst
franziskus sich zur Flüchtlingspolitik
des Landes geäußert bei einem Treffen
mit geflüchteten dankte er Ungarn zwar
einerseits für die Aufnahme ukrainischer
Kriegsflüchtlinge gleichzeitig mahnte
der Papst allerdings das ist wichtig sei
Mitgefühl für alle zu zeigen während die
Regierung von Ministerpräsident Orban
ukrainische geflüchtete mit offenen
Armen empfängt verfolgt sie ansonsten
einen strikten anti-migrationsplan
die Leipziger Buchmesse hat gleich zu
Beginn schon ein echtes Ausrufezeichen
gesetzt der Literaturpreis der Buchmesse
geht an einen
Gabelstaplerfahrer der nebenbei am
Niederrhein einen Verlag für Lyrik
betreibt
der Einzige in seiner Einwandererfamilie
der gut deutsch sprach egal wer beim
Arzt bei der Bank einen Termin hatte
sagt der heute über diese Zeit ich wurde
wie eine all die Tüte mitgeschleppt
er hat sich in eine Sprache
vorgearbeitet die sich ihm schließlich
ergab schreibt die Neue Zürcher Zeitung
über seinen grandiosen Roman unser
Deutschland
überhaupt will die Buchmesse in diesem
Jahr großes über Themen soll gesprochen
werden nicht nur über einzelne Bücher
Leipzig will ein politisches Zeichen
setzen Stefan Kelch
bei der letzten messekannte die Welt
noch keine Energiekrise weder
galoppierende Inflation noch Corona und
keine Ukraine Krieg all das muss nun
Platz finden auf der wiederbelebten
Messe und ein altes Dauerthema
Deutschlands Osten und Westen finden
einfach nicht zusammen die altkanzlerin
erinnert sich am Abend das sogar sie als
Ostdeutsche schon deklassiert wurde als
lediglich angelernte bundesdeutsche
Gedankenlosigkeit die einfache Abgründe
blicken lässt ich glaube es hängt
einfach damit zusammen dass ich zu wenig
für die Westdeutschen geändert hat durch
die deutsche Einheit oder wenig
und für uns eben sehr sehr viel und dass
diese Änderung dadurch nicht
eingedrungen ist die Biografie so sieht
das auch der Leipziger
Literaturprofessor Dirk Oschmann sein
politisches Erstlingswerk Bestseller und
Dorn im Auge vieler sein Thema solange
sich der Westen als Norm definiere
bleibe der Osten immer die Abweichung
natürlich ist es keine wohlfühl großer
der man da begegnet das ist unangenehm
man kann sich auch mal nicht neutrale zu
verhalten und ich fand es aber wichtig
und vielleicht ist den Diskurs neu in
Gang zu setzen Jammer aus wie Melodie
oder Paukenschlag Autor Frank Richter
könne aus mein Buch zwar nicht leiden
der übertreibe manchmal unerträglich
aber im Grunde sage er nichts Falsches
der besten war nun mal in Blick auf die
Wiedervereinigung Beitritt zum
Geltungsbereich des Grundgesetzes der
vermeintliche Sieger der Geschichte und
hat viele Dinge eben dann einfach auch
auf den Osten übertragen weil die
Menschen im Osten noch mehrheitlich das
damals so gewollt haben später hat sich
die Sache verfestigt und jetzt müssen
wir neu darüber reden wie wir in
Deutschland Zusammenkommen der Vater von
Autor Florian Havemann war einer der
mutigsten DDR
Oppositionellen als Florian Anfang der
70er Jahre in den Westen floh
interessierte sich dort niemand für
seine ostbiografie heute ahnt er warum
ich meine wir sind alle nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg gleich rausgekommen die einen
haben Glück gehabt im Osten hat man Pech
gehabt aber seine gleiches wir waren
hier auf dem gleichen Stand oder sowas
und da stellt sich die Frage ab für
jeden bester doch auch welche
Opportunist geworden werde ich Karriere
machen wollen wem hätte ich mich
eingelassen das ist der Grund warum man
sich nicht für uns interessiert hat wenn
man sich diese Frage nicht stellen
wollte dieses Desinteresse des Westens
könnte fatale Folgen haben meint
Oschmann das ist ja einer meiner Impulse
dass ich sage wenn der Osten den
Eindruck hat nicht bei der Mitgestaltung
der Demokratie mitmachen zu können wenn
er nicht die gleichen leben scheinen
bekommen dann wird es auf Dauer diese
Demokratie an den Rand ihres
Zusammenhalts führen und dann
interessiert sich vielleicht am besten
der goschmann habe sein Buch eigentlich
für westdeutsche geschrieben verkauft
wird sein Bestseller aber zu 80% im
Osten
und wie jeden Samstag jetzt der Blick
auf die Lottozahlen die lauten 9 13 14
23 24 40 Superzahl 0 alle Angaben wie
immer ohne Gewähr
fehlt noch das Wetter dass ich in den
nächsten Tagen zumindest teilweise sehr
freundlich zeigt Morgen meist sonnig
oder nur locker bewölkt vor allem im
Süden aber auch ein paar dichtere
Wolkenfelder Höchstwerte 11 bis 20 Grad
am ersten Mai im Norden viel Sonne im
südenschauer und Gewitter am Dienstag
unbeständig Mittwoch wieder überall
freundlich und trocken 11 bis 20 Grad so
viel für heute gerne bis morgen die
nächsten Nachrichten gibt es hier gegen
0.25 heute Express mit Sarah Wildau
[Musik]